Hey how's it going bros
My name is PEWDIEPIE!
Today is a very special day
I have in front of me, Walking Dead, season 3
Now Walking Dead, is a very dear game series to my heart
I loved season 1, I loved season 2
And here we are with season 3. FINALLY.
I'm really excited to see what's gonna happen
OH, get The Walking Dead Michonne
I THINK NO THANK YOU THAT WAS GARBAGE
And if season 3 is like that I'm gonna be well fucking pissed
Now, the reason why-we all love The Walking Dead
is because of Clementine, okay
Greatest character of all-all time
Maybe a little bit of a- *inaudible*- exaggeration but we are
invested in this character okay
And Kenny, alright. I care about Kenny
Erm...
Cause-
How many hours have we spent on this you know?
I'm, I'm invested
I think you are as well if you're watching this and if you're not
Check out season 1, right fucking now
NOW
Sh- we-I know this okay.
So we get to choose how we uh...
Let the story off right cause choices matter
No they fucking don't
Start a new story
Ah shit I already fucked up
Eh... fuck
Okay, wait WHAT? So episode one and two are already out
WHAT?!
OH, they never done that before
That's a strange move from Telltale
Let's give it a go I guess
So we're gonna continue our story
Recreate your story?
OH WE GET TO-AHHHH SO CUTE
AHHH, so we
We, we shot him
After Lee's death, Clem found more survivors
People who helped her, such as Kenny
Clementine remembered the joy she felt with Kenny
It depended on, family
Thanks to her companions, Clem's journey ultimately led her to
We led- we led us to Wellington
That's the ending I really liked
I think we should enter Wellington, I think that's more interesting
Let's just start, I am very confused
This seems like a lot of difference, changes huh?
Okay interesting, there- it's barely visible, can't see it
Ooo I'm nervous, I'm very nervous
Okay, let me tell you. You know, in season 2
I didn't have my save file either and you had to replay
the entirety of season 1
Which let me tell you is the most BORING thing you could possibly do
Cause there was no fast forward
You have to be careful
Alright
Already we fucked up
Every time, every fucking time
Okay? Every fucking time I swear to god
Show the fucking subtitles
This looks cool
This is before
Shit happen I suppose
The good old- This is what Americans dream
Sitting on your front yard, front porch drinking
Oh it's as it's happening
Ooo will he turn perhaps?
Why do I care? I don't know who these people are
Clearly running over there
Oh my god it's potato boy
With our fists
WHERE'S CLEMENTINE?
Yeah get inside potato boy
Potato bitch
Potential boyfriend material for Clementine
Oh my god
Sometimes you just gotta fight it out and not be a little bitch afterwards ya know?
See they just-
See they got it out of there
Girls are just passive aggressive instead
What?!
Now kiss
Sorry
I don't know, I don't know, I genuinely don't know
They said silence is a valid option
Are they suppose to be Spanish? Cause they really don't look-
Is it just me?
I fell on a
ice skating range
No
So we played baseball. I'm sure we're gonna get a baseball bat later as a weapon
Something's happening in the background out of all this
It seems like the outbreak almost
Oh geez
Why's everyone hit me!?
You got that right
Telltale presents
That's a bit weird time to put in the title
I never understand when they do that
I like this, cause then we get to experience the outbreak which I think is a very exciting part
to- to be experiencing a
an apocalypse
Grandpa is DEAD
BITCH
OHHHHHHHH THAT'S CREEPY
That's- nice, nice. I liked that
You probably should not be, okay
alright *tsk*
Jesus
Skybound know that this is their baby
They know they can't fuck this one up and it's going well so far, I enjoy it
OH, MY GOD
WHOA, GRANDPA'S GOT MUSCLE
He's just confused, yeah cause he's fucking dead
Don't let her bite her
Okay well
She's gonna die
HEY HEY
Yeah potato boy where is she?
No one cared that grandpa came back alive?
Yeah, you might want to walk
Seems like they're trying to do like Last Of Us you know, when they started up
Oh he got a scratch too huh
Oh shit boy
You dead
It's like he knows
It's just herpes okay, calm down
It's very nice
I get stressed out okay
Hey look it's jacksepticeye
I take every chance
that i can get
Who the fuck are these people?
Maybe we should go, I've never seen so many
I miss the soundtrack
Is that a ghost one? What the fuck is that?
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT ONE?!
Did you see that?
See, I can point with this now
Listen...
Before you judge me, can I be a hipster okay? Jesus Christ
Where's Clementine?
Car crash in 3, 2,1
Eh, triggered. There's a hula girl
Did you see it?
Should we be smoking now? Yeah seems like a bad idea
They're asleep!
Shut up!
So... Her husband is dead?
And he was stubborn!
Look at that hula girl!
You're gonna be a *inaudible*
You're not my fucking mother!
What the fuck is that quote?
What the fuck
Wait, what, what happened to Walking Dead?
We're talking about boners and periods right now
What the fuck is this?
Where. Is. Clementine?
It's been 18 minutes and I have yet to see Clemy clue alright?
Wanna pull over?
Don't worry baby I just need 15 seconds
Ah shit 10!
Fucking hell I'll take 5!
We're smoking weed, go back to sleep, we hit a skunk
Huh Mariana
I want to know how many days after the outbreak is
Hey I got an achievement. wow ah
That feels great, thank you Gabe
Is anyone else- do you actually care about achievements?
Like I could not give a big shit
Aw nice
What about a Walking Dead game without a little bit of walking is it?
Someone needs to do better quality control over these, like just play through it slowly and be like
OH, something happened there like, I do it with my videos all the time just to make sure
like it's so easy when you make cuts and stuff
I'm not saying it's the same thing but still
It kind of takes away the immersion a little bit when you see a weird
movement, with their bodies
That isn''t suppose to be there
Alright well, maybe I'll get to use this eh
Oh, it switched to my keyboard, great erm...
Why did he do that?
Is that a joke?
We do bottle flips
Oh no, it's jackseptic-
OHHH shit
Alright, B
I pressed this
Jesus Gabe
Dude you look nasty
And here he comes for the strike
Oh I see, this is the guy, in front of the beginning
I'm so stupid
Did that click for you right away?
Aw man I feel stupid
Of course it's him I-
Oh that's the daughter! Oh my god
Terrible idea to wear headphones in a zombie apocalypse
Did- tell me honestly, did that click for you before it did for me? I'm sorry if I'm stupid
Okay, I didn't think about it. So we're the guy from the beginning
Potential Clementine boyfriend material
which is why I'm excited
This is cool, I get to walk with my flashlight
Hey there
So we got Mariana and my name is, something else. I don't remember
And we're looking for barrelss
Look at the barrels
Okay, he's walking over
This is pretty cool
I can dig it
How do you know the difference just by looking at it?
Was that a pantie flying around? Did you see that?
Hold RT to walk faster
Maybe you can siphon gas from this car?
EMPTY
I don't care about that, what you think about it
Si- si, how do I- okay so siphon
We, we hit it, and then we
Okay well let's hop on- hey I got a crazy idea
How 'bout we si-siphon
That's a weird looking siphon
Si, si, shut up
Bing, badaboom
Badabing, why am I doing this? I don't know
All I care about is Clementine
This is game not real
Okay
How 'bout we climb up this ladder? That seems like a good diea
So one eh
One part of Scare Pewdiepie season 2
Spoilers
It's going to be Walking Dead
I'm very excited
It's probably one of my favorite episodes
Yeah let's stick together
That seems like the right thing to do Gabe
I did something. Literally me
Something that probably would have seen anyway
Maybe he can find some medicine in there
They changed the control systems like that
It's a bit weird
YEAH
Is that all they contribute? Fucking smiling
Get the fuck out of my way, my sight
I don't need that shit in a fucking zombie apocalypse
YEAH
I mean, it's kind of a tiny
Alright, what?
So why don't we, enjoy ourselves a little bit?
Okay well let's uh check here
You can break the window, you have a crowbar
Nope
Apparently not
How about that
OH NO
OH, OH HIS FAULT. Oh god I hate bald people
No offence bald people, I don't hate you, but I hate bald people
Why?
THAT'S RIGHT BALD PEOPLE GET SOME HAIR
Looks like we shouldn't go there
Gabe give him, give him your beanie fast
Uh oh
I don't like this
What the fuck was that sound?
Alright
I suppose we should go in here?
Gabe what are you doing?
You can back out or we can look in
Be careful now
OOOOOOO
Okay why? Why do people want to get into the hatch?
'Kay then let's back out
Move this
Oooo secret entrance
Hey Gabe why don't you help?
Instead looking inside of cars
Here we go
Why does Gabe have a gun and not me?
Fuck I'll be terrified. I'll look behind right away
I wouldn't be yelling either. Sorry I'm just thinking if this is me okay
No dead ones at least
That's right
I understand some other languages
I understand Russian
Oh my god
Avocado, wow
You start looting that
Hey batteries, aw
That's cool
DIP SAUCE!
Look at that shadow there on the green left
Shadow from the pudding
Walking Dead do you want me to play tests?
Your games
I- I'm happy to do so
That's actually good
Don't care, don't care
I think we should keep moving. Actually if there's-
Sh-shut
Shut the fuck up, I'm trying to think here
That's a terrible idea and you're a kid so shut the fuck up
If there's a herd coming after us, I want to keep moving okay.
I don't care if it's uncomfortable
Plus I want the sex tonight if you know what I mean
Pound it. I am so sorry what is-
Okay
Hey, I got batteries
I wouldn't normally give it to her, but since we have to be kind of a dick you know
We- I figured I could give it to her
You know I have nice qualities too, believe or not.
Thank you very much
You're welcome
OH JESUS
What the fuck?
Damn it
Aww
Well I'm already grabbing it
And later I plan to grab some ass
Up top!
Not just gas
You got it
I don't know it was yours
Okay, everyone calm down
What's wrong with his face?
Time to kill some people
Sorry Lonnie but you're gonna be Bonnie, I mean buying, buying
Goodbyenie
Shit, what do we do?
What do we do? I don't know
Ooo
Oh we gonna fuck around
We gonna fuck around real good
You can take off that stupid hat
What are you fake hipster?
Sorry, okay
Yeah that's right, slide that shit
Hey no that's ghost please
I just said we
Ow
Oh no
That was a raccoon
It's my pet raccoon Steve
Please don't hurt Steve
I don't want to kill Lonnie
Lonnie is my favorite character so far and he's so awesome
HIIII
Okay he did it anyway
See I didn't do that
I'M SORRY LONNIE I LOVE YOU
But you gotta go
Aw Lonnie no
Alright Mr hipster boy
Oh god he's- aw shit
He's gotta shout it
Hey I didn't kill Lonnie
Lonnie killed himself
Uh oh
Ow... Fuck
Shit
Fuck shit shit fuck shit fuck
Got that back shit in
Here we are, sleeping in the van
No we're not, we got hit by the head by  other people
Aw they got one of those zip ties
Thanks
WHOA SHIT
OH FUCK SHIT
OH MY GOD
Damn that was loud, that was very fucking loud
HEY look at that it's a gun
Well I better- aw it's a shame if I-
OH NO I HAVE THE GUN NOW
Oh that's too bad
Why did the tree fall? What are they fucking on?
Hey asshole
OH FUCK ME DUDE
I'm a good shot, how 'bout that?
Aw oops
Why did I shoot him? Now I feel terrible
Well at least it wasn't Lonnie
OHHHH, I RECOGNIZE THAT VOICE
I KNOW THAT VOICE
OOOOOOOOOOO
CLEMMY CLOOO
Oh my god she's so pretty
Oh my god Cl- SHE'S A BADASS
SHE GOT A FUCKING SPAZZ
No she's not a kid, she's a fucking badass
Oh my god, okay, alright
We're gonna end that episode there
Cause oh boy, that was exciting
Erm... okay
Now, I realize I could make this episode up to a little longer
but I want to keep it like a daily series
cause I think that's a really fun way to watch
Well let me know if you want uh, want to see more or less or whatever
Uh I do value your opinion cause we're doing this together
And
Yeah, I'll see you tomorrow with a new episode, this is so exciting
Oh my god
Clemy's back!
YES! CLEMY'S BACK!
Thank you for watching. I'll see you tomorrow
As always, stay awesome bros!